the great scholar al-hasan al-basri
was passing by the marketplace in basra iraq and he hears people calling others to come
purchase their products and in particular he hears one man with buckets of ice and this
man says o people have mercy on the one whose capital is melting away the man
is trying to urgently quickly sell his ice before it melts away this is a famous
story al-hasan abbasid allah starts to think of time imagine you and i we had a
sense of urgency to use our time wisely before it melted away like this man was
using his time wisely to sell his ice before it melted away
do you have a sense of urgency with your time or are you reckless with it
do you allow it to disappear we consist of time hours and days and minutes and
seconds and for some people years and decades once an hour passes it doesn't return it
doesn't return until the day of judgement to testify for or against you allah reminds us
in the quran in surah in allah mean allah has purchased from the believers
their lives and their wealth in exchange for paradise you're using your time in this world
whether it's 20 years or it's 120 years for the sake of allah
and your wealth and as you use your time for the sake of allah there's a
return on your investment the return on that investment is allah will grant you jannah for
how long how much time do you get in jannah for worshiping allah subhanahu wa it's
eternal and so you can see obviously that the most reasonable thing for any one of
us to do is to use this time limited time that you have as wisely as
possible for an investment that is eternal in nature when you think of how society
protects things and the way that there are security measures for things that people value for
example with banks and security at banks with pieces of art and jewelry around the world
the types of security that you hear about or you see and so on and so
forth people protect things that they value and oftentimes for example when you value your life
you're going to take measures to protect your life when you value your home you might
put an alarm system for example to protect your home because you value that thing you
protect it the question is do we protect our time there are many things around us
that we protect in society many material things but do we protect our time are we
very cautious or do you allow anyone and anything that wants your time to take your
attention away to kill your time to waste it the most precious blessing that we have
it was reported once that a righteous scholar on his way to the mosque to the
masjid to pray was stopped by a man who was known to waste a lot of
time and the man said something along the lines of can we go and kill time
or let's go and kill time this might be translated as let's go kill time let's
go chill for a few hours in other words let's go just waste time and the
scholar responded back to him and said can you hold the sun for me meaning can
you stop time so that i can kill time when you say i'm killing time and
you think i want to kill time in other words you are saying i'm killing a
part of myself because you consist of time do you protect your time do you value
your time for the sake of allah subhanahu wa wisdom necessitates that the believer is protecting
the most precious thing that they have and if you were to be asked what is
the purpose of life why do you exist hopefully your response is based on reality allah
who created us told us why we exist allah
the one who created death and life in order to test you to see who's best
in their conduct it's all about your good deeds it's all about the worship of allah
the pleasure of allah the pursuit of paradise may allah grant us that so if you
know what the purpose of life is the question is how do you attain it how
do you facilitate it other than through your time so you must to protect the purpose
of life you must be protecting your time and yet the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
two blessings
good health and free time and think about the example of the one maybe yourself family
member or others when they fell ill or they went through a severe illness may allah
protect us and grant us shifa and our loved ones around the world but when that
person fell through or experienced a type of illness they wished for their energy to come
back so they could worship once again they wish they could do things like they had
not done before the time that they had wasted when they had good health they wasted
that opportunity and that energy and now they are regretting it and it's not coming back
to them as well as free time use your time wisely before you have more responsibilities
before things get more difficult generally speaking for the believer there isn't time to waste there
isn't time to kill there's no such thing as i'm bored i have nothing to do
there's always something to do with the limited time that you have but you must first
value it in order for you to protect it as a beautiful quote from a scholar
and i'm taking only two parts of this quote but he said essentially know that your
mind cannot contain everything so dedicated to the most important of matters your mind consumes many
things you are exposed to many things every day now if you're someone for example who
uses any digital devices or accesses the internet on a daily basis you're exposed to many
things every single day you're exposed to media you're exposed to things you watch the videos
movies entertainment tv shows the books that you're reading whatever it may be you're exposed to
social media you're exposed to the news in general you're exposed to your work your career
your studies choose wisely the most important of matters because your mind cannot consume everything and
you have to choose the things that are prioritized the things that are important the things
that are beneficial if you're wasting a lot of time for example on fiction on things
that are fake the things that are uh useless the things that don't have value and
may even have doubtful or prohibited matters within them ask yourself the following question does it
make sense for a person to spend an hour two hours three hours every single day
every day of the year watching uh characters and watching people pursue their false or fake
dreams through these movies and tv shows while you're killing your time not pursuing your dream
for the sake of allah not pursuing your purpose in life know that your mind has
limitations you cannot take in everything you cannot do everything so dedicated to the most important
of matters and know that your day and your night are limited and you have some
essential needs so make sure that you are managing the times of rest and the times
of activity for the sake of allah